if you have blurred vision or other
complications due to a cataract in the
lens of your eye your doctor may
recommend surgery to remove the cataract
the lens is a clear disc that receives
light through the pupil and focuses it
on the retina to help produce a clearer
image
the lens is mainly composed of water and
proteins as you age
these proteins may begin to clump
together and cloud the lens this
clouding is called a cataract a cataract
can block light from entering your eye
and cause blurry vision
before your procedure you will be given
eye drops to dilate your pupil and the
area around your eye will be washed in
most cases you will be given an
injection of local anesthetic around or
behind your eye you may also be offered
a sedative to help you relax
most cataract surgeries lasts less than
an hour
the most common method for removing
cataracts is phacoemulsification in this
procedure your surgeon will look through
an operating microscope and make a tiny
incision on the side of your cornea
he or she will make an opening through
the capsule of the lens and use an
ultrasound probe to break the cloudy
lens into tiny fragments next your
surgeon will vacuum out these fragments
through the incision then an artificial
intraocular lens will be inserted
intraocular lenses are made of plastic
silicone or acrylic compounds and will
remain in place for the rest of your
life
because the incision is very small
stitches are generally not necessary
vision often improves notably
immediately after surgery
after your operation a patch will be
placed over your eye and you will be
observed for a short time to be sure
there are no problems such as bleeding
cataract surgery is performed on an
outpatient basis so you will likely go
home the same day
since exposure to bright light may
initially be uncomfortable make
arrangements for someone to drive you
home